[Musique]
deux adolescents tués dans des
affrontements entre bandes en quelques
heures le bilan est lourd la première
c'est une collégienne de 14 ans tué d'un
coup de couteau à saint chéron dans
l'essonne
quand on a des enfants de 13 de 14 ans
qui ont déjà parfois connu d'ailleurs
des méfaits avec la police ou la
gendarmerie
c'est bien sûr l'autorité des parents
qu'il faut remettre en avant il ya une
notion d'éducation de renforcement en
accompagnement de ces jeunes et des
parents qui sont parfois confrontés est
tout seul à devoir affronter ces
situations-là des familles
monoparentales la culture de la défausse
s'est jamais de la faute du gouvernement
c'est faux on sait que jamais de la foi
du gouvernement qui dit aussi qu'il
annonce 100 policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires sur place très
rapidement et vous oubliez un mot
ponctuelles ne peut pas tout mettre sur
le dos des parents car l'état de la
société est à ce point est tendue dans
tous les domaines j'écoutais ce matin
sur sur votre antenne le problème de la
drogue
je ne cesse de le répéter trop facile
d'accuser céphalées parents quand on
fait pas son boulot parce que c'est sale
et donc le boulot et l'état je vais vous
dire ce qui se passe c'est que cette
semaine vous avez où étaient les forces
de police cette semaine vous avez où
elle était sur les carrefours à harceler
les français qui étaient pas 18 heures
chez eux tout ce que l'on peut voir
contre la police eux aussi viennent d'un
trafic en des milk d'un pratiquement
aujourd'hui il faut le dire tous les
quartiers de france dans l'avenir soit
devenir président du hac soit devenir
président de la république vous
choisissez quoi président du hac
écoutez est drôle de question
en fait non il est pas drôle est
sérieuse mais oui ça y est ils ont passé
les 10 millions de vues ils ont droit
je veux dire à leur apéro à l'elysée
paie pas la peur on doit être super
président de la république un oui l'on
attend en tout cas c'est ce que madame
lacroix a promis ils ont un travail peur
et en deux jours seulement j'ai pas la
question du destin national
la question c'est là la question du
dessin qu'est ce qu'on fait de la france
dans les 30 ans qui viennent dans les
cinq ans dans les 30 ans qui viennent
c'est une question qui est absolument
redoutable pardon mais c'est une
question sérieuse et on peut pas
l'aborder en fin d'émission comme ça on
transmet un message du président de la
république
le message est grave au défi relevé et
réussi
je tiendrai mon engagement envers vous à
l'elysée la journée de la dernière
chance pour dunkerque avant un éventuel
en confinement avec 900 un cas positif
pour cent mille habitants
le taux d'incidence dans la communauté
urbaine de dunkerque et plus de quatre
fois supérieur à la moyenne nationale
toutes les mesures que nous avons prises
jusqu'à présent pour contrôler le covin
sont totalement inefficaces
la situation se dégrade et elle est même
préoccupant très préoccupante dans une
dizaine de départements et dans certains
territoires impose même des décisions à
des mesures rapides et fortes
en réalité contrairement à ce qu'on
pensait le sar ce n'était pas transmis
majoritairement par l'environnement ni
par les contacts directs qui auraient pu
être évitées assez facilement mais qu'
il y a eu des gens qui ont été
contaminés jusqu'à 200 m des personnes
infectées
ainsi à dunkerque et dans la communauté
de communes des hauts de flandre ce qui
représente environ 250000 habitants à
compter de vendredi soir et jusqu'au
lundi matin un confinement sera
désormais adapter le week-end donc dès
ce week end
donc c'est le sahara mais comme il dit
pas ça ce candidat moi je pensais que
c'était le tarse d'aujourd'hui
pardonnez-moi mais effectivement vous
avez parfaitement j'ai un petit peu
avant la non mais vous avez raison il
parlait brossard effectivement et je
l'avais mal interprété une pluie de
cendres orangé et les coulées de lave
qui dévalent le long des parois du
volcan c'est la cinquième fois depuis
une semaine que le volcan sicilien
l'etna est en éruption
o2 3324 m l'etna est le plus haut volcan
d'europe en activité